for the first time since president biden
took office we are getting an unofficial
look
inside a border patrol facility for
unaccompanied children take a look at
these pictures from
donna texas they show kids crowded
together in makeshift
rooms democratic congressman henry
cuellar shared these images with axios
at the time at the number of
unaccompanied children in the u.s
at this moment are in custody the
american custody has now grown to more
than fifteen
thousand and our manuel bajorkas is on
the mexican side of the border in the
city of juarez mexico manny good morning
to you
what's the situation where you are
well good morning we have seen pockets
along the border where people
are getting through to the other side we
have also noticed u.s border patrol
agents
quickly spot them and in many cases
apprehend them
some migrants tell us what they are
fleeing from is a bigger factor
than any change in u.s immigration
policy
within minutes of arriving at this
stretch of the border with el paso just
on the other side
we saw a man with a child in his arms
and a woman rushing across
and into the united states
they appear to be spotted soon after
we're told that many families are still
just trying to get to the other side
to turn themselves in thinking they can
claim asylum but the biden
administration says most families
will be sent right back it's what
happened to glenda mendes of guatemala
to see you as human beings trying the
best for your
children she and her fourteen-year-old
son gustavo
have been living at a migrant shelter in
juarez for a month now
so how's it all been
very difficult
a lot of dangers here in mexico they
haven't considered sending him a loan
though the biden administration's policy
toward unaccompanied minors
would mean he could stay in the u.s
while his case is processed
republicans have blamed the president
for the crisis
the message is coming back that hey we
got a new president
come on in on sunday homeland security
secretary alejandro mallorcas
repeatedly said that was not the message
the border
is closed current policy is that
migrants whether they cross illegally or
through a port of entry
apply for asylum in the united states
president biden said the administration
is working to change that
we're in the process of doing it now
including making sure that we
re-establish
what existed before which was they can
stay in place and make their case from
their home country
but many people like mendez say waiting
is not possible
so it was more the fear of the threats
against you and your family
that brought you here not necessarily
the policy no further necessary
president biden said he may visit the
border but did not specify
exactly when in the meantime mexico says
it's beefing up its presence
along its southern border where central
and south american migrants
are streaming in tony all right manuel
thank you very much